John Allen a former president of the CBI
which has obviously been engulfed in
allegations of sexual misconduct that
led to the departure of its former
director General Tony danker last month
on the back of that all of those
allegations uh came in the Guardian
newspaper which subsequently reported
that allegations had been made against
John Allen now he's the chairman of
Tesco very very experienced UK
businessman worked in the logistics
industry for a long period of time very
much a respective figure in the industry
in in business more generally and Tesco
says that when these allegations came to
light it looked into them very very
seriously it makes clear in this
statement that three of these
allegations are vigorously denied by
John Allen for the other he unreservedly
apologized for the comment he made now
that was fairly comprehensively reported
in the guardian at the time which was a
suggestion that to add a CBI event he
complimented a female employee on what
she was wearing and said that dress
really suits your figure and that is the
incident that he has acknowledged took
place and as I say he and Tesco making
clear that he's unreservedly apologized
for that and for any offense that he
caused uh the other three allegations as
I say he categorically denied Tesco has
looked into them uh one of them related
to the Tesco annual general meeting in
2022 Tesco instigated an investigation
by its lawyers it called for employees
to come forward us for uh anyone who had
any evidence of that it also studied
video footage of the meeting and uh
Tesco has basically said that the scope
of that review has been considered by
external legal counsel the advice that
what they did was reasonable and
appropriate in the circumstances and
that it's identified no evidence against
John Allen for any inappropriate
behavior on that particular occasion
however what the company has gone on to
say is that as you just said Bell in the
introduction there John Allen these
allegations surrounding him were risking
becoming something of a distraction to
the company it's worth pointing out that
John Allen has been chairman of Tesco
since 2015 and under normal corporate
governance rules you would expect him to
have stood down before he reached the
10th 10th anniversary of joining the
board and that in any case uh the hunt
was well underway for his successor so
he's stepping down early uh with uh as I
said a search for his success of being
well in trained to avoid any further uh
distractions for the company now he's
going to be replaced on an interim basis
by Byron groat bar and groat is very
experienced oil industry executive spent
many many years in the top echelons of
BP it clear it's clear from this
statement he's only going to be there on
an interim basis while they seek to
appoint a permanent successor asked
chairman for John Allen he's going on
the 16th of June which is when Tesco's
annual meeting takes place which I think
is quite significant content itself
because I think if Tesco were really
really concerned about this they would
have asked him to step down straight
away and that hasn't happened I mean
stock market criminologists on these
sort of occasions we like to look
through the statements and some will
draw attention to the fact that there
isn't a comment from John Allen in this
Stock Exchange announcement that's gone
out from Tesco this afternoon I wouldn't
read too much into that necessarily on
the basis that he is going to be around
for another month also